Dave, Gabe, congratulations.
You've made it into the final
round of this competition.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forges us to recreate an
iconic weapon from history--
the yatagan.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Good luck.
[music playing]
DAVE: I've been assigned
to make a yatagan.
I don't know how
to spell yatagan,
but here I am making one.
I've never made a
blade this long,
and I've never made one that
requires such an ornate handle.
So I'm nervous.
This is going to have to chop
through a pig, a thigh bone,
maybe try to cut
through Wil's biceps.
I don't know.
I'm going to make it to cut.
I think I've got
the curve right.
I think I'm sitting pretty.
Gabe, my competitor, is
a very competent smith,
so hopefully I'll have
a blade that will stand
up and equal or surpass his.
GABE: It is very important
to get the rough shape today.
And if I do not get the rough
shape knocked out today,
then that'll throw the rest
of the four days way behind.
I don't have a power
hammer or a forging press,
so I have a lot of work ahead.
This is my power
hammer right here.
I think I'm the underdog.
Dave's got the upper hand.
He's been doing it
for a lot longer.
It's his to lose, I think.
And I hope I'm going
to come in there
and sneak and take it from him.
I really like the shape.
Dave, you're going down, buddy.
DAVE: Today, the plan is
to make my mokume billet
for the bolsters and
the ornamentation that
goes on the side of the blade.
Mokume technique in Japanese
means "wood grain metal."
It's laminated nickel
silver and copper.
And I'm squeezing them
together under high heat,
and they should bind.
I'm going to create
an interesting pattern
in the steel.
All right.
That's for later.
It's quite time-consuming,
but I think the end product
will be worth it,
assuming it takes.
That's hot.
Now I see if I've
got a viable billet.
Yes.
Not molten.
Also a good sign.
This better be worth it.
One thing I'm concentrating
on the most today
is making sure
everything is symmetrical
and getting ready
for heat treating.
Feeling a little nervous.
If I have some things out
of whack, then it'll pull.
That's one way you
can cause warps,
but I'm praying and hoping
that's not an issue.
[music playing]
Hmm.
She has developed.
I have a nice warp.
I don't have time to
make another blade.
I have to fix this warp or
I have no shot at winning.
[groans]
I'm going to clamp the
blade in a position
so that the warp
is overcorrected,
and hopefully it'll fix
itself in the temper.
Otherwise, I have no idea
what I'm going to do.
DAVE: The mokume came out great.
It was worth it.
And yesterday, I
quenched the blade,
and it came out
straight and hard.
Today, I'll start working
on the ebony handle.
So that to that.
I chose ebony because
it's really pretty wood.
The material's a
little brittle, but I
think it should be just fine.
I'm not really sure if I got
this thing fitted properly.
Gonna hope for the
best right now.
Success.
I would like the test
to be on a banana--
a nice, soft banana.
But I suspect it's going
to be a giraffe or a fire
hydrant or a cuckoo clock.
I don't know what they're
going to come up with.
I hope it does well.
[music playing]
GABE: I fixed the warp as
best as I possibly could.
The goal for today is to
be dialed in on the handle.
I'm going with this marble wood.
It's already square.
It's got some width so that
I can sculpt in the ears.
We are all together.
This sword I have dubbed
"Dumbo" because it
looks like an elephant.
Everything's come together
into something I'm proud of.
Let's go whack
something, shall we?
That's a pretty clean cut.
I'll call that a day.
Bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do,
I'll take your yatagan
and deliver slashes and thrusts
on this ballistics dummy.
Dave, you're first.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
DAVE (VOICEOVER): I'm
so nervous right now,
and I'm just hoping my
blade will perform well.
[music playing]
He's got bowels
dropping out everywhere.
Let's talk about
your weapon, Dave.
It follows the
feel of a yatagan.
It's supposed to be
light and deadly.
The edge you have
here is sharp, where
it's curved in to lacerate.
Your yatagan will kill.
Thank you very much.
All right, Gabe, your turn.
You ready?
Go nuts, man.
Let's do this.
GABE (VOICEOVER):
Dave's blade performed
seemingly really well.
Guts falling out of the
thing and blood everywhere.
So a little nerve-racking
knowing that it'll have
to at least measure up to that.
[music playing]
All right, Gabe.
It is so light.
It really feels
like it's not there.
It's almost scary.
When I thrust, it penetrates
easily and slashes down.
Overall, sir, your
blade will kill.
Thank you.
DAVE (VOICEOVER): I think
we cut quite similarly.
I would prefer to be
ahead, but right now I
feel like we're neck and neck.
All right, gentlemen.
This is the strength test.
To test the strength
of your weapon,
I'll be chopping into
these bones six times.
Dave, you're up first.
Hacking bone is
a very difficult
thing to do with a thin edge.
I'm aghast knowing what's
going to be coming.
[music playing]
All right, David.
That's a tough test.
Those are very thick bones, but
what we've got going on here
is a lot of chipping and
distortion on your blade.
We've also got a major
crack in your handle that
runs right up through the pins.
All right, Gabe.
Your turn.
You ready for this?
Go nuts.
[music playing]
OK, Gabe.
The convex edge
you've got on here
is pretty much the perfect
edge for a test like this--
sharp and strong.
I can feel just the
smallest amount of a roll.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
Next up, the sharpness test.
For that, I give you Doug.
DAVE (VOICEOVER):
I have edge damage.
I have handle damage.
It's disheartening,
but it's not over yet.
Bladesmiths, to see if
your blade is still sharp,
I will take your weapon and
slash through these silks.
If your blade is still
sharp, it should cut cleanly.
If not, it may rip or tear
or, worse, do nothing.
Dave you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right.
I love the balance
of your blade.
I like the way it
curves in, but you
can really feel the edges now.
It's serrated.
It hangs up with silk.
But then on the last piece,
just when it's nice and taut,
you can lacerate
and cut through it.
Overall, your blade
will still cut.
Thank you.
All right, Gabe.
It's your turn.
You ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Gabe.
Your blade is so
light, you're barely
like cutting through air.
I glided through
this, lacerated,
and of course, in the
finishing cuts here,
cut easily through that silk.
It cuts.
Good job.
Thank you very much.
Bladesmiths, you both created
remarkable finale weapons.
But in this arena
of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that champion is--
[music playing]
--Gabe.
Congratulations, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Dave, your weapon
did not make the cut.
Dave, you brought us
an outstanding weapon.
That yatagan is fantastic.
But during the strength test,
we lost structural integrity
in the edge of your
blade and in the handle,
with both scales fracturing.
And those are things we
obviously can't overlook,
so that's why we're
going to let you go.
Sure.
Dave, please
surrender your weapon.
DAVE (VOICEOVER): It's
exactly what I expected.
It was very difficult
testing, but I'm
still the guy with the cracked
edge and the broken handle.
It's like going out
with a beautiful blonde
and finding out she has BO.
And my blade has BO.
Gabe, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
I've never seen
anybody less stoked
about getting 10 grand
in my entire life.
Why don't you please present
that weapon to the judges.
GABE (VOICEOVER): It feels
great to be the "Forged in Fire"
champion, but I'll
do my celebrating
behind closed doors.
I felt like I was the underdog,
but underdogs win sometimes,
I guess.
[laughs]
[music playing]